when i was in the coal industry it was
feast or famine
everything's going great and it's just i
shut down
some eggs man yeah i went from working
in a coal mine blowing up the mountains
and now i'm planting stuff on top of it
you know reclaiming it back
[Music]
my name is chris farley and i'm a farmer
for refresh appalachia
it's okay buddy refresh appalachia has
come to these abandoned surface mines
and we're turning them into active
agriculture farms
this one will probably get to be about
five feet tall everything you see here
was once an active coal mine what are
you doing today hey hey
the way i like to do is just kind of
step on it and wiggle it almost
everybody that works for refresh
appalachia was a laid off coal miner
we have chickens that fertilize the soil
we have goats that eat the tops off the
bushes
and we have the hogs that come in and
they're like a plow they tear up all the
rocks and the soil and get it ready for
planting
[Music]
this soil is so tough we have to use
pickaxes
slate bars
just try to break it up it's tough
perfect i started in the coal mines
right out of high school
[Music]
i just followed my father's footsteps
i used to work on the surface mines for
over 11 years similar to what you see
back here the first six years was good
and after that it was every six months
to a year i'd get laid off times were
real tough
garden looks good how much rain have you
had down here my grandmother and
grandfather had a farm their whole life
they went through the great depression
and pictured my grandpa they didn't
struggle at all because they had their
own farm hey granny how was the sweet
potatoes this year last year they were
really good
my grandma she's old but she's taught me
a lot about gardening and that's
something i've grown up loving yeah i
started out farming
went to the coal mines now i'm back to
farming back to my roots we'll have this
much coming first and then this bunch
will come in
if i had an offer to go back into the
coal mines right now i definitely
wouldn't take it i'm hoping that we can
have the strip jobs working
we can come behind them planting like
we're doing right now
there's opportunity there
we can work together and make it happen
you